heart
we are told heart is uh
genetics it comes from your mom and dad
and you know
every time i go to the doctor to ask me
a question did your mom have a heart
attack no how about your dad my dad has
13 heart attacks really yes
how old was his first one 44 how many
has he had 13
has he had an open heart surgery yes
does he have stents
yes three of them how many angiograms
he's had six angiogram six angioplastics
you gotta be careful because you may
have it right
so what they don't know is my dad smokes
cigarettes two packs a day for 30 years
and he drank a full glass of alcohol
every single day
for 30 years is what he did i don't
smoke i don't drink so what is the cause
of heart disease
and why heart attacks take place
so you know we're going to execute
just remember just remember sixth grade
sixth grade
simplified for us all right i'm trying
i'm trying my best patrick
um first of all uh here's
you know we have to base every answer i
give i want it to be based
on fat right observations and fat
so fact number one um in 1920 in this
country
there was almost no heart disease
everybody acknowledges that
in fact there's an interesting story
that a guy invented the ekg
at harvard medical school offered it to
the harvard faculty and
they said there's no use for this
there's no heart disease in this country
and whenever traditional indigenous
people are studied
they have no evidence of heart disease
they have no evidence of dying of heart
attacks
now i don't know about your concept of
genetics but we're talking
two or three generations ago we went
from almost
nobody having heart attacks and by the
way if you look at a cookbook from 1920
and you say what were the healthiest
foods that people should eat
it was very clear butter lard and eggs
and cream nobody had heart attacks
the fact that now in 1940 just one
generation
later it became the number one killer of
americans
there is no possible way that has
anything to do with genetics
see now i got smarter tom
i'm telling you what a difference it
made in the first 45 minutes and now i'm
telling you
that was ridiculous so 1920
no heart disease just two or three
generations ago in a 1920 cookbook
they're talking about butter lard and
eggs in 1940 a generation later they're
calling that the number one killer
so who wrote the 1940 cookbooks and who
made us think that these things kill us
with heart attacks and then when do we
start having heart attacks
we started having heart attacks with the
two
major things happen one the major
change in the american diet again away
from healthy fats
and towards margarine crisco and other
processed foods three things two
the second thing was the widespread use
of chemicals
in agriculture and food and ddt
and all the rest of it and three was the
increasing
electrification of the earth which we
now know interferes with your ability to
generate
oxygen and to use oxygen so as soon as
those
three things happen you see this
epidemic
this epidemic of heart disease
now here here's another thing patrick
you know
if you ask a hundred doctors 100 lay
people
100 people off the street why do people
have heart attacks
right they say the exact same thing you
have these three major
coronary arteries they carry all the
blood to your heart
one of them gets blocked with plaque or
two of them or three of them
the blood can't get through and then you
have a heart attack and die
right sure everybody knows that yep
you're with me we're
i'm with you this part i'm with you
sixth grade fully qualified
got it okay now let's dissect this out a
little bit
uh i've seen probably a hundred people
come to my office
say 50 year old man uh
let me stop for a minute here let me go
back a little bit
so would you agree that if there's
something blocking your arteries
it's probably in your blood
sure right second question
do you think the blood in your art and
your coronary arteries the heart
arteries is the same blood as you have
in your spleen
and liver and foot and everywhere else i
would assume so
yes i would too okay so the blood
leading to your spleen
has whatever it is that's causing the
plaque just like
in the coronary arteries so you must get
plaque in your splenic artery
as well right sure yes
now how many people have you heard of
who've had spleen attacks
[Laughter]
i've never heard of spleen attacks so i
i've given lectures to maybe
50 to 100 000 people in my career
one of the questions if i'm talking
about heart please
raise your hand if you've heard of
anybody or know of anybody
who had a spleen attack a liver attack a
foot attack or a kidney attack
you know how many people raised their
hands none none
now next question how many of you know
somebody personally or
in the news who had a heart attack
plenty 100
sure how come
same arteries same blood same plaque
how come next question
guy comes to me i've seen this probably
a 50 times
maybe a hundred times because i wrote a
book about the heart i have a medicine
yeah people come to me 50 year old guy
doc i walked up a hill i felt a little
pressure in my chest
i went to the doctor he said oh you
might have heart disease we gotta
check your arteries does an angiogram
says you have a 95
blockage usually they go like this and
if you block
anymore you're going to die of a heart
attack right
i've heard that a hundred times let's
think about this for a minute
we're told that all the blood to your
heart goes through those three arteries
right sure that's why they unblock them
you not you but the guy who came to me
blood flow through your artery okay
how did you walk up that hill
next question you mean if you not you
but that guy you block from five percent
to three percent
that's gonna kill you
i don't believe it five percent is no
blood flow
three percent five percent exactly the
same
there is no evidence that that makes any
difference at all
next thing there was the biggest study
ever done
on people who died of heart attacks they
did it with autopsies
a guy named giorgio beroldi what year
was it
what what year was it
2000 something so this is recent it's
not our 20s or 40. it's a reason
if you want to read the entire book if
you're a glutton for scientific
punishment go to
heart attack new dot com at the bottom
there's a print version parody
prints the whole version does autopsies
50 years on people who die of heart
attacks
he says 41 of them have a blocked arter
and of that blockage 50 come after the
heart attack not before
so if you do the math that means that 80
of the heart attacks have are have
no evidence of any blockage in the in
the artery leading to that part of the
heart
none now the when i wrote the book i
pointed that out
and said what is the reason why these
other 80 percent die
and in fact if you look at the studies
of stents
and bypasses right so these are
mechanisms or
strategies to clear out the arteries if
it was just a blockage it should work
every single one of them the conclusion
is there's no evidence
that having a stent makes you live
longer or not have a second heart attack
and then in october 2018
in the lancet for the first time they
did a
blinded study of stents right so they
took
i don't know how many i think 70 people
who had a
single vessel blockage right
half of them they put a stent in the
other half they put a catheter in they
told them they put a stent in but didn't
and they assessed them eight weeks later
they had the exact same amount of chest
pain
so not in the headlines of the article
was
stents proven useless now
it's therefore proven that stents don't
prevent
further heart attacks they don't make
you live
longer and they don't help you have less
chest pain
and so it's very difficult to say so
what is the benefit
and i can't think of any and in the
article they said
there must be something else that is
causing people to have heart attacks
and essentially then the european heart
association
redid their typology of heart disease
and said
60 to 80 percent of people who have
heart disease
signs and symptoms have no evidence of
any plaque buildup so essentially the
whole plaque thing
at most it has to do with 20 percent
and the fact of the matter is most of
the blood flow to our heart doesn't come
from this
these arteries anyways but it it is
basically a watershed with millions of
little capillaries
just like a watershed instead of a river
and when you have disease in how you
generate energy
then you have a heart attack